Chris can you please give us a 10 minute
version of what the hero's journey is
yes the hero's journey I I'm going to
give you the quick uh down a dirty
version
there are in the way I look at it I
broke it into 12 stages and it doesn't
necessarily have to be
chopped up that way you can describe it
in 10 stages or as Campbell did
sometimes he would take 16 or 32 because
he was interested in telling you every
possible thing that could happen but I
cooked it down into this rough outline
of 12 stages because I I was trying to
get something that could be useful in
many many many cases for analyzing
scripts basically so I came up with this
12 point uh
proposal of of what the story really is
down deep so the first stage is
The Ordinary World you need to introduce
the character the main character the
story is about you have to introduce the
world they live in and let us know
what's been going on there up to this
point uh so this is like a stage that
you create on the screen and you bring
your characters out and introduce them
to the audience and show the character
doing something uh characteristic their
characteristic Behavior a way of getting
on in the world but in that opening
section there should be some kind of
clue we're going someplace else or
there's a problem here that needs to be
solved or there's a question will the
hero escape from this world will the
hero get what he or she wants will they
learn what they need
so this is an opportunity to set those
things in motion and kind of set the
table for the audience of what they need
to know to get involved and drawn into
the store Story the second bit
is the stage of Call to Adventure
because you really need to announce to
the audience that there's a problem that
needs to be solved or there's a desire
somebody has and that generates a lot of
energy in the story and draws Us in
because we are just programmed to
observe anybody even stick figure
drawings
and plug ourselves in to the desires of
that stick figure uh if if it's reaching
its little stick hands out uh to pick up
a baby or something or to get food we
automatically plug into that so the Call
to Adventure is announcing to us hey
here's somebody who's kind of like me
and
um they want something or they're in
trouble or they need something or their
world is in trouble so uh it's a way of
announcing that and I've noticed uh
there is a strong tendency to play
certain kind of music at this point they
go to the Brass section and they play
horns you'll hear a lot of horn calls
like bugle calls on the soundtrack at
this point so the composers are
instinctively going for that kind of
sound
so the next thing that typically happens
in stories is uh there's a reaction so
the Call Comes how does the hero react
and that's the third stage which is
usually refusal of the call most of the
time they put up a fight about it of
saying I don't want to go or I can't go
or I already went once and I didn't like
it there'll be some kind of statement
like this or turning away from the
adventure that's being offered and I
think this is there for a very important
reason it's to tell the audience this is
scary and your hero is naturally afraid
because he or she is being asked to go
into the unknown they don't know what's
ahead and we're all afraid of that we
might want to get out of our situation
in our Ordinary World if we're
uncomfortable as most heroes are but
uh what's next is unknown and so it's
natural to express fear and there are
some variations on this some heroes are
really into it and they want what they
want and they are just ready to go and
nothing's going to stop them but
somebody else in the design will often
jump up and say you can't do that don't
you know this is terribly dangerous
everybody who tried this was killed and
there are a lot of things in fairy tales
and myths that suggest this the hero
will be walking along the path trying to
get what he wants to get into a castle
or to rescue a princess or something
like that and notices that the ground
underneath is very crunchy and making
all this noise under his boots and he
looks down and realizes he's walking on
the bones and skulls of all the heroes
who went before and didn't make it so it
is signaling to the audience this is
serious this is dangerous and we really
need that to get involved in the story
or else we just go oh well it's you know
some cartoon or you know uh uh
string of images that I'm observing that
aren't really meaningful to me it when
we get scared for the hero then we're
involved so now we have to overcome this
fear and a typical way is stage four
introducing
um a mentor
and the mentor is a character often
who is wiser and more involved than the
hero has been around the block once or
more times has been through the whole
hero cycle of 12 stages more than once
and they're there with really one job
which is to reassure the hero and give
the hero something you could equally
call this type of character a donor
character because often they give
something to the herald might be
knowledge might be a map might be a
magic sword might be a weapon or a
vehicle of some kind or just reassurance
that no I've I could I'm here to tell
you it's scary of over there in this
other world but
it can be survived and I went there and
I know because you look I'm here so you
know that someone can survive this so
that often is used to give the heroes
some reassurance and there can be
stories that don't have this uh uh where
there's no mentor and that's kind of a
scary story when there's nobody to look
up to nobody to ask about what are the
rules in this other world what can eat
me what should I eat and uh you know
who's a friend and who's an enemy when
there's nobody to ask that's kind of a
horror story and that makes an
interesting variation and I think that's
a good point for all of these stages
that this is a very flexible system and
if you take out or leave out certain
parts it creates a very interesting
tension where the audience kind of
expects it and they want to know why
isn't that there usually that's there
and that I see there isn't any helper or
Mentor
so this is maybe a different story that
I should pay more attention to so it's
good to be flexible about these things
so next thing up stage five is now that
you have sort of uh loaded up your with
equipment and reassurance and you know
where you're going you know what you
want you face your fear you've been
reassured now it's time to get up and go
and when I was working for the movie
studios especially for Disney they
talked about this like an airplane
taking off and they said you've spent
all this time in what they call the
First Act the first three or four or
five movements uh those first steps
you've loaded the plane up and you've
fueled the plane and you've told
everybody to Belt their seat belts and
you know all the safety things now get
the wheels up and get the plane in the
air so uh this is the feeling of lifting
up that you get when all the preparation
is ready and now we're going into that
new world or special world as Joseph
Campbell calls it he says every story he
ever looked at seems to take place in
Two Worlds either environments or states
of being two different states of
conditions so now we're going to really
launch into that special world and this
is a big
turning point in a story that signals
the audience all the prep is done now
we're really going for it and the
audience likes that and they feel a nice
lift there and sometimes it's backed up
by changing the music or the change in
the energy of the scene to say we're
leaving Kansas we're leaving the
Ordinary World and now we're going
someplace very very different and exotic
so now you're in this special world and
you have to figure out what is special
about it so there's a stage number six
that's called tests allies and enemies
and the idea is that it's like you've
been thrown into a college class and you
don't know much about the subject but
they've given you a few chapters to read
and some problems to work out and now
you're tested but it's a small test it's
like a pop quiz that just focuses on
certain skills and abilities and so the
hero will be put through some kind of
challenges that aren't fatal necessarily
but they're a little scary and a little
dangerous and they bring attention to
the fact I don't know the rules here and
I've got to figure it out fast so I got
to figure out who can help me with this
and and who will be in my way and that's
where the allies and enemies come and
often you will find teams are built at
this stage you think about in Star Wars
the Cantina sequence where you're on the
threshold of this world of space and the
hero Luke Skywalker finds you know the
rules are very different here there's
weird creatures and quick moments of
violence so the hero is alerted that
he's going to someplace quite exotic and
different
so having been through some of those
tests there's a stage now because number
seven which I call the approach and this
is a period of time in movies and in a
lot of stories where the hero is not
quite to the center of the whole thing
yet but there's a period of traveling
there and on that travel the hero and
the rest of the team get to know each
other better and the first impressions
that you made of people and the
impression you have of yourself may
start to change because you're getting
to know them better so it's a period I
would call another name for it is
getting to know you where people develop
deeper relationships the friendships get
deeper or they get tested and you become
suspicious you might be paranoid about
the other person or you know somebody
sabotaging us and you know who is it and
you start looking around for suspects so
this is a place where comedy can develop
and where romance and Intrigue can
develop uh it's a Time
in stories where you uh sort of let your
belt out as a Storyteller and take some
time to go deeper with the characters
so this all is by way of leading up to
uh sort of the heart of the whole thing
the mainspring is stage eight which is
the ordeal and uh this is composed
really of two beats one is death or a
near-death experience or a confrontation
with death and then a rebirth that comes
out of that and it may be stretched out
over two scenes one for the death and
one for the rebirth or it can all happen
in one scene but this could be a very
drastic uh very dramatic scene often you
will have physical
combat at this stage or legal dispute or
a big argument in the family something
like that and it there's blood on the
floor and it looks like somebody's gonna
die or sometimes somebody does die and
in a lot of the myths that's exactly
what happens uh the hero actually dies
and goes into an underworld or is
swallowed by a creature uh and uh you
know to our eyes to ordinary humanize is
dead and over with but they're living in
this other world and uh in the
underworld or uh they get a second shot
at life and are brought back uh
transformed because the ordeal they went
through was so intense that it shatters
the old self and now they get to be
something different and uh this will
sometimes come as a surprise to the
heroes and to the audience that oh I I
didn't know I had that in me I didn't
know I could survive and face something
like that I thought that would wipe me
out and it did but I still have
something left and and I feel
differently about myself now
so uh those are are huge transformative
scenes and sometimes very violent and
sometimes very dramatic
the simple way to say it is that the
hero faces his or her greatest fear
whatever it is they're afraid of should
be established earlier in the picture uh
earlier in the show but uh at this point
they they face that fear and keep going
so the next stage number nine is reaping
the benefits of that it's called the
reward Stage Nine and here is where
sometimes you have the rebirth or this
is the aftermath of that death and
rebirth where you take some time and
reflect on what just happened and sort
of recompose yourself and begin to
experiment with this new identity that's
come because you went through a crucible
you went through something
transformative and scary and now you're
not quite the same person anymore and
you need to reflect on that and often
it's literally reflecting by looking in
a mirror there are a lot of scenes in
movies where people at this stage take a
good look at themselves and begin to
realize you know I I thought I couldn't
do the X Y or Z and you know what I can
and maybe that means I could do
something else too so they'd be begin to
dream bigger or have a better idea of
themselves and it will often be
expressed in a long speech and
thoughtful speech where they're going
over what just happened and and
reflecting on you know when I was in the
jaws of the monster or when the bad guys
were about to beat me up uh I I had a
thought and that thought comes out and
sometimes it's a profound thing that the
hero realizes about himself or herself
so having done all this sort of
operation there is a kind of a party
atmosphere almost at this stage you
might celebrate uh on this moment of
rebirth but
um this reward phase but at some point
you kind of have to collect yourself and
the energy of the story to focus now on
finishing and this is something that
mirrors or or corresponds really well to
what goes on the life of the artist the
artist uh dives into something not
knowing what it's going to be they pull
something out of themselves that's very
intense uh they almost die doing it I
think almost every artist has that
feeling that it wasn't easy to get it
out of me but now it's out there uh it's
wonderful but now I have to publish it
now I have to bring it home now I have
to polish it and finish it so that it
can be presented and the same is true
for the heroes and the stories they
sometimes have to
rededicate themselves to finishing and
there's a increase in energy here and
often in movies you find Chase scenes at
this point where the urgency becomes
apparent that we better hurry up because
the bad guys are almost home and they're
going to claim the victory before us so
we have have to race them to get home or
the bad guys stole the treasure that we
came to get and you know we had it in
our hands but now it's gone and we have
to go chase after it or somebody we love
has been kidnapped by the villains and
we have to pursue them so the the energy
of the chase often comes up if you
looked at 100 Hollywood movies you would
find at least 80 of them have a very
exciting chasing at this point
so this is a a place where you can
almost see home but there's a lot of
trips and uh possible uh flaws and
outcomes that can yet trip you up
so uh with that increase in energy now
we come skidding into the next to last
phase number 11 which is the
resurrection which is an umbrella kind
of phrase that covers a lot of possible
operations but basically it's the climax
of the movie where uh all the questions
are brought to the fore and are answered
in one particular choice that the hero
makes or one action that the hero takes
to stand up to the villains or to seize
their Birthright and there might be a
big Showdown or a conflict physical
fight sword fight gun fight or courtroom
battle or big argument between the
generations but it serves to focus the
heroes energy on how have I changed them
what have I learned and I'm going to be
tested here to the Max this is the final
exam
stage eight was kind of the midterm exam
this is the final and if I flunked this
final I'm doomed I'll have to either
repeat it or I'm going to end up killed
so it's as drastic as it can be but it
has this wonderful effect if the hero
faces it faces Their Fear and calls on
all the things they've learned in the
story then they end up transformed and
can express all these things they've
learned in a single action and
bring out a wonderful feeling in the
audience that the hero is now fully
realized and has learned the lessons
and has defeated the uh the bad forces
although it should look like the bad
guys are going to win and we should be
tricked almost into thinking that they
have the upper hand and then the hero
pulls out one last burst of energy or
gets help from somebody and uh is able
to overcome and then the final step
stage 12.
is what Campbell called return with the
Elixir and the idea here is
once you've been through such a
transformative experience that's churned
you up you have an obligation and
sometimes a desire to share it with
everybody else and that's what really
makes a hero according to Campbell's
idea of the word hero is that it's
someone who protects and serves and
doesn't do it selfishly that they do it
with a sharing kind of attitude and that
that's what really distinguishes a good
hero is that they take responsibility
for a group that they
um
step up or that they sacrifice something
at the last movement
that was very dear to them but which is
good for the community so there's often
a sense of expansion here that the
hero's little world and their little
desires and needs have a bigger
Dimension and because I went through
something dangerous and faced my fears I
have something to share I have something
to give and it might be a good story or
it might be love or it might be a new
way of doing things
new idea of yourself but it must be
shared and transmitted and that's the
idea of the Elixir which is elixir is a
word from Arabic that means a magic
potion or magic dust that has this
quality like the Holy Grail of healing
all wounds or solving all problems and
uh it's a a universal
antivirus that that is everything so
that's the 12 stages as I see it and
it's a beautiful pattern that kind of
promises you if you uh
observe these things and celebrate them
in your story that they'll be a payoff
in the audience that they will feel
something uh and that their life will be
shifted or their view of the world will
be shifted just a little bit and maybe
they'll have a bigger idea of what's
possible for them